okay I'm going to talk about the
statistical analysis that we did in
connection to asthma that was a long
term project that we carry with the
Department of Health in Florida the
plague was motivated from a social
perspective and one point and also from
a scientific perspective because the
school of science where I belong to is
pretty interested in getting into system
biophysics and asthma is one of the
emergent diseases or emerging conditions
that involve a lot of differences
systems inside the human body and a lot
of people might be impacted by the
result of this project and one of the
idea is just to translate that into
medical applications okay so I
distributed the presentation into the
motivations that I just mentioned a
little bit the statistical analysis
using Mathematica packages and and then
we're going to go through some kind of
biophysical applications and how we can
use Mathematica in order to address all
these points okay there is a fact in
meteorology exactly in bio meteorology
that they're cold front coming from the
north of United State when they move
south in different moment of the year
they produce episode of outbreak of
asthma at emergency departments so
typically in the northern side of United
State in a period of our September they
are producing high peak at emergency
department and sometimes people are
calling that the school epidemic peak
and but then that's the same thing is
moving south and by the title of january
and februari so that peak of emerging
department visit due to asthma are rich
in South Florida there is some kind of
time series of the number of emergency
department visit in some of the state of
a united state but there is not an
overall surveillance problem there's not
any auto surveillance program collecting
that kind of information for two reasons
one of the reasons and Steve just have
mentioned at it yesterday in the keynote
speaker dinner it's pretty hard to get
access to the health data so to convene
hospital or Department of Health to
release that kind of data is now very
easy in all state specifically in the
state of Florida they started to run a
surveillance program for the last eight
years and I was fortunate to work with
the Florida Ozma coalition and a brace
project and they were very gentle to
provide the data that we use for that
project okay so mainly I will focus on
and three other County de árbol on that
belong to the southeast of flurry of
miami-dade Broward and Palm Beach there
they are ranking like the third fourth
and fifth Connie with the number of
asthma cases reported at the emergency
department most of the cases of asthma
are reported in a central part of
Florida and in the north center part of
florida there is some kind of micro
climatic conditions first that
apparently are favoring that number and
second there is a lot of social cultural
issues related with the disease and the
third category social cultural events is
pretty important because Florida asthma
coalition's has put forward a product of
asthma management make school with free
of asthma and when people are just
getting training on how to manage asthma
the number of recurrent visit to the
hospital has dropped significantly so
that's some of the things as you can see
from all these three graph there is a
time series of a number of emergency
department visit over time the time unit
here are taking us the day after January
first two thousand five so that's the
reason why you see okay 365 could
respond to the end of the first year and
so on so we we made it a relative unit
because it's easy
we process it with time series analysis
okay if we look at the one particular
miami-dade County we did this marine and
we try different i would say strategies
using moving averages we use in quantile
regression we use it a nonlinear feeding
we tested three different software in
order to look for consistency our for
sensitivity we did it with Mathematica
we did it with origin as a software
which is pretty common and we did it
with our so we tested that thing with
three and all three software that were
very consistent in telling out that
there is a periodic signal impose it on
a very very slow quadratic background so
when you do the decomposition of the
time series we look at the mean number
of cases per day for every year with the
standard deviation and we plotted the
data in a standard unit in C valuable
and when you plot it in C volleyball you
can see that the number of cases are
going beyond the first standard
deviation making that a very significant
event not just and the margin of the
error okay later on we look at the okay
there's a seasonality though the weather
conditions supposed to be involved in
that we use a matematica to get access
to the word information from the time
series the data time from all the
airports around the South Florida we got
all that information and then we did it
the correlation analysis between the
number of emergency visit and a
particular unit that we found a
correlation with the largest value to
our surprise even so that the graph are
there they look pretty similar now when
you do the correlation linear
correlation you will see that the
coefficient of variation for those are
no higher than fourteen percent when you
do individual correlation for for
example the minimum temperature and when
you look at the mean temperature for the
day so the largest value for the
variation that you can get is 17
sentative aria variability which is a
surprising event because the graph look
pretty similar and then we look at the
lagging effect how many days in advance
so how many days people are getting
exposed before they go into a
consultation and then we saw that even
if you use the minimum value of the
temperature the variability that you can
explain with a simple where event is no
more than twenty four percent so that if
you use a linear correlation analysis on
wood now you can go to a multi linear
correlation also and the result that you
will get are not much better than the
one that you get with the linear one now
if you do a poison analysis which is
pretty common in those cases because
this is an interval you have the average
over the interval then you can look at
the up the up in favor and the art
against and then you can estimate how
many cases can be changed if you change
the weather conditions and then you get
a much better picture and you get like a
more sensitivity to the water condition
about that increase in the sensitivity
if you use a poisson regression it's
going to be a little bit much better
than that but you never will see their
correlation coefficient of the order of
seventy percent or eighty percent
capable to explain the variability of
that we tested the same thing with the
humidity the general change of humidity
and then we'll look at actually add a
combined it parameter that is called the
net effective temperature which is a
kind of a wind chill effect but it
involves now humidity it involve the
speed of the wind civil taneously and
such as the real temperature people are
feeling it's a physiological chamber
that you feel so when you look at the
picture you can see that the pattern for
the net effect is temperature pretty
much reproduce that drop in temperature
coincide with the peak in the emergency
rooms department visit so but if you do
the correlation analysis you will see
that that correlation analysis is about
the seventeen percent
I ability also very similar that when
you do that with a regular minimum
temperature which is telling you that
the weather is not the direct cause of
the impact of the number of cases of
asthma at the emergency room however the
weather might be an indirect comorbid
factor and we were exploring that before
than anything else so we look at the
speed of the wind and and then we look
at also at the environmental condition
we look at the number of so the counting
of ozone ground soon and Miami and and
the data is showing that the ozone
concentration is below the standards
required by the EPA actually if you try
to do a cumulative effect of also on our
time you will see that the correlation
that you have in the increase in the
number of cases is extremely small so
also an in Florida doesn't played any
role or some play a role in the
northeast of United States for Boston
and all the area of massachusett that
part way there than which a high
concentration of ozone ground on soon in
my play the role but for Claudia it
doesn't play the role and it might be
understood pretty easy if you look at
the Windrose which is the polar plot
that you do for the speed of the wind
and the strain of the wind so hows turns
to winning in what direction the wind is
blowing most of the time the state of
Florida since it is a very narrow
Peninsula and the wind it's very strong
so either the wind is taking any kind of
pollution into the lake okeechobee or
outside into both of the either the Gulf
of Mexico or into the Atlantic water so
pollution is not a problem for state of
flooring so it take me to the point that
weather conditions is still in there but
in which way the weather conditions are
affecting the number of people over
there okay then we look at the physics
and physics just uh the the main point
of that and what part of physics thermal
physics so the you can cover your body
when there is called you can just get
everything
you clothing however the only system in
your body that you cannot cover out of
interaction with the environment is your
respiratory system so your respiratory
system is completely exposed to the
environment and you are a changin it
completely and continuously with the
environment so then you have heat
dissipated during respiration they're
coming in two ways convective heat and
evaporative heat that evaporation that
you lose in during the process of
respiration is extremely important and
in my produce for example that you open
respiratory tract my loose humidity and
a humid layer that usually is located in
the upper respiratory tract protect your
upper respiratory tract from bacteria to
or viruses to get into the epithelial
cells so when you dry in these out so
you're exposing yours epi tell yourself
to viruses that might be hanging in the
air okay we're looking at that and we
compete it how much turmoil is stressed
you might get depending on the month of
the year and you can see there that in
the first month of the year in January
February and then you you see that again
and note from november to December you
can get the highest thermal stress on
the upper respiratory tract so now
weather is not a direct effect but it's
producing thermal stress and now you're
talking about relational stress and
response from the body to that stress
now when you have a respiratory tract
under stress you first there's two
things that happen your immunity usually
drops and second the channels for
viruses to get into your body are
opening more easily so if you explore
that possibility you you will see that
even on the daily basis if you go to the
to the stress on the
daily basis you will see that most of
the time by the end of every period you
got most of the negative terminal stress
which means as a stress due to call at
the end of the year here in the area of
South Florida which means you got a lot
of losses and a lot of try out in the
upper respiratory tract it took me or
the group of people who work it on that
project team that supposed to be a
relationship between the temperature so
the weather and then like influenza or
any kind of biases that usually are
present during the wintertime in many
areas of our United States there are
sensitive viruses there are influenza
viruses and there is a another group of
family of viruses that are very present
some people will show that like a
symptom in a symptomatic way some people
might show that in very direct
symptomatic way and the very dry air
which is very common during the months
of winter are very proactive for more
bacterias and viruses to get into your
upper respiratory tract so which take me
to analyze the problem of asthma base it
on a very no model that is called as I
are modeling epidemics susceptible
infected and recover individual thinking
about the asthma in that case in South
Florida Elise is epidemic trigger it so
means all those respiratory tract
infections might be the triggering
mechanism for them but if you solve the
as I our model which is a model that
include a constant of rate of
transmission from susceptible to in
infected individual so usually that is a
constant and then you're going to see
that you got a peak in the epidemic and
then immediately that peaked I up
however is that constant is modified
using a seasonally forcing infection
rate and you saw that as a right model
with a system of differential equation
so then you're going to see a completely
different pattern you will see now that
you have periodic oscillations in the
number of infected and recorded
individuals and if you are too damn
model a new compartment including the
exposed individuals that are
asymptomatic that might have a period
for them to get sick so then the number
of oscillation and the chi-square
testing with the experimental data so
the number of cases is much better in
that case so that is is telling us that
the supporting favor of epidemic
modeling is much better than things that
we that did it before so we then modify
the more a little bit and we introduce
it explicitly the exposure individual
and then the exposing individual might
have a probability Q that they might
become infected and they have a
probability 1 minus Q that they are
becoming a symptomatic carrying the
disease but they are not showing sign
and with the time they might show the
sign and they might become with a
probability P infected direct individual
and then you go to the face of record we
change the system of differential
equations we solve the problem and when
you solve the problem so you got a
pretty okay if you can see the the
infection rate constant data Chi the
kind of solution you get if you get the
infection rate and the latency period
with the variability of periodicity that
we found in the in the time series you
get then a pretty good wrestle a pretty
good reproduce reproduction of the
experimental result that motivated us to
look at the system up a part of the of
the asthma as a combination of the
immune and endocrine system a
response to the thermal stress we
created the system graph for all the
mediators from the pole dry air to the
air narrowing that might be involved
with the system of differential equation
that will result out of that it's a
pretty complicated one and these are the
modeling changes that we're expecting
now it's a system of nonlinear 16
equation with different time response so
you have a system that might respond
pretty fast system that might respond
very slowly and now you need to make
compatible that these two time windows
and this is one of the challenges that
we are facing now with the modeling and
also the last challenge that we are and
involved now and I'm very thing for this
visit now because I learn now how to get
the matches for the upper respiratory
tract hear from our America and discreet
discreet discreet the size that mesh so
that I can solve the problem of fluid
dynamics with thermal distribution I
have to solve those two things but now I
have the backbone from the upper
respiratory tract and I know ready how
to get the match to do that so in
conclusion as Miss and emerging the
disease which is three very indirectly
by weather conditions what a condition
percent now responsible for the episode
of asthma weather conditions ality
evaporative losses then there this might
be a pretty good source for viruses to
get into the system and upper
respiratory tract infections are the
mechanism that seems to be the most
important in South Florida and the
system biology approach that we're
getting into now is more consistent with
the six different federal type of asthma
documented by the literature asthma is
not a single at my son emerging disease
which mean mi cama from different
pathways and the reason for that just
telling that in mathematical terminology
your you
or physiological description is a system
with different metastable state and now
depending from which metastable stage
you move on or you move from that the
federal type of asthma you will get so
that's the reason why you might get
people that might get a Sonoran
allergies or you might get people that
might get a thought just because they
eat it too much one day it's because
it's depend on the federal it depends on
the metastable state do you have there
and in order to explain that you need to
involve the endocrine system and immune
system because endocrinol is pretty
easily related with the processes in
that your digestive system and your
psychology your mud system and the mood
immediately will also influence your
immune system so that's where is
something that we call narrow and the
cream immune interaction so it's a three
system that I working together and you
cannot separate one from another say
that I just want to acknowledge my
institution for sponsoring this research
plus sponsoring the attendance to this
conference the Florida ask my coalition
and the brace project for providing all
the data and then they're working and
three of my student who working in that
project before with me Gerald Avila he's
a greater BS in mathematics from our
institution and he's hiding already by
the University of Colorado Boulder
Ashley Perez she graduated as a BS in
mathematics and she now worked for the
Miami Polly day school and she's the
last student that came from miami-dade
College during the summer research
institute and she did all the molding
about the epidemics is a biology major
who learned matematik in one month and
she did a great job so which is telling
is that for me was a sanity check that
biology student might learn computing
and they could do a pretty great job
that was the midterm by all this dude
can now learn matter would learn
computing so choose to prove that it
could be done thank you for your
attention
you